die richtigen Fragen hier bei Bild jetzt
an Bayerns Ministerpräsident Markus
Söder grüße Sie herzlich Herr Söder in
München haben Sie das Gefühl haben Sie
den Eindruck dass es sich in Deutschland
als Normalverdiener im Moment lohnt
morgens aufzustehen und arbeiten zu
gehen
es ist zumindest eine große
Herausforderung auf der einen Seite
haben die Menschen wirklich Sorge durch
das untätig sein und zum Teil durch die
Fehlentscheidung der Bundesregierung und
auch den Streit den es in der innerhalb
der Ampel seit Wochen gibt breitet sich
große Sorge aus wie wird es mit dem
Winter werden und die Sorge besteht
insbesondere für viele der Mitte
Normalverdiener dass sie am Ende dieses
Winters zu Geringverdiener werden und
frieren müssen und erhebliche Sorgen
haben auch was die Zukunft zu dem
Arbeitsplatz betrifft ich würde die
Situation und Sorge der Menschen als
sehr ernst einschätzen worum es ist
wichtig dass die Bundesregierung endlich
handelt und zwar nicht mit dem kleinen
Besteck sondern groß anlegt den Menschen
Vertrauen gibt und auch ihnen
tatsächlich die Sorge nimmt dass es zu
der größten wirtschaftlichen Krise der
Bundeswehr Deutschland gekommen wird
dann legen Sie das große Besteck einmal
auf den Tisch was ist das große Besteck
was ist jetzt braucht
also wir haben gestern und ich habe
gestern eine zehn Punkte sofortbaden
vorgelegt er hat folgende wesentliche
Bestandteile zum einen mal mehr Energie
zu mehr Energie gehört natürlich die
Verlängerung der Laufzeit der
Kernkraftwerke bis Ende 2024 der drei
bestehenden und im Zweifelsfall auch zu
einer reaktivieren von den drei die es
kürzlich abgeschaltet wurden zweitens
wir brauchen dringend alle
Kohlekraftwerke ganz nett zum möglichst
viel Energie zu haben nicht nur zwei es
könnten weitere 16 Folgen drittens es
braucht ein Weg der gasumlage und das
Einführen eines
gaspreisdeckels nur das hilft all diese
ganzen einzelzuschüsse und alles
Ausgleichsmaßnahmen werden keine Wirkung
haben die gasumlage weil sie den Preis
verteuert muss weg und weil sie möglich
ist und der gasdeckel muss her damit man
verlässliche Struktur hat verlässlichen
Preis für Bürger und Mittelstand und es
braucht es übrigens nicht nur für Gas
das braucht es auch für Strom und meine
klare Forderung auch für den Sprit das
wird von allen ignoriert es glaube dass
das ganz dringend und Rettungsschirme
für Stadtwerke noch dazu und auch für
soziale Einrichtungen die im Moment
darben an dieser schwierigen Situation
alles zusammengenommen ist die einzige
echte Chance dass wir nicht nur die
wirtschaftliche des wirtschaftliche
Desaster abwenden ist die einzige Chance
dass Menschen auch wirklich gut durch
den Winter kommen und ist auch der
wichtigste Beitrag auch die Demokratie
zu stabilisieren in Deutschland sie
haben die gasumlage schon angesprochen
und nochmal gefordert dass die wegkommt
aber Fakt ist die tritt jetzt erstmal in
Kraft am 1 Oktober obwohl eigentlich
niemand die mehr will außer Herrn
Haarwerk aktuell und der sagt auch schon
daher nach drei Monaten ist dann
vielleicht Schluss aber die tritt
erstmal in Kraft die muss man erstmal
zahlen jetzt die sollen sie wie wollen
wir alle das ja noch verstehen
ich verstehe es nicht ich verstehe
ohnehin die Bundesregierung nicht leider
auch ein Habeck nicht das ständige Hin
und Her zeigt zum einen einmal das wohl
offenkundig der Überblick über die
Energiepolitik in Deutschland verloren
wurde bei der gasumlage hat der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister gesagt naja er
habe die Gas den Gasmarkt nicht so ganz
übersehen können darf kann es ein
Bundeswirtschaftsminister sagen er
meldet jetzt verfassungsrechtliche
Bedenken an nachdem er sie selbst
eingeführt habe hat er das nicht vorher
geprüft alles sagen die Bereiche der
Kernenergie sind dringend notwendig zu
verlängern
erkennbarer Weise ist eine rein
ideologische Entscheidung des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers und bei all
dem verunsichert gerade den Mittelstand
das wohl das ökonomische Einmaleins das
jeder beherrschen sollte das eigentlich
jeder Wirtschaftsminister seit Ludwig
Erhard als als entscheidenden Punkt
versehen sollte nämlich dass man erstmal
Geld verdienen muss dass man es ausgibt
oder umgekehrt werden nichts produziert
und nichts verdient der geht am Ende
eben auch leider dass all diese Dinge
entweder nicht funktionieren oder der
Überblick verloren ist das verunsichert
zutiefst und führt auch dazu dass jetzt
die gasumlage vielleicht doch
beschlossen wird obwohl sie keiner will
ich kann nur ehrlich sagen ich mache das
nicht parteitaktisch das wäre völlig
falsch wir wollen solide und seriös
durch diesen Winter kommen aber uns
fehlt ehrlich ein kompetenter
Ansprechpartner in der Bundesregierung
dafür würden sie sich zutrauen zu sagen
wenn die Union im Bund regieren würde
dann wäre der Gaspreis dann wäre die
Gasrechnung im Moment günstiger die
Energierechnung
ganz klar man hätte ja seit Monaten was
tun müssen schauen Sie die Verlängerung
der Kernkraft die deutliche Einsetzen
von mehr Kohle das akquirieren von
anderen gasmöglichkeiten übrigens auch
dass sich Sorgen und Pipelines nicht nur
im Norden sondern auch im Süden und das
verspätete Eintreten für flüssiggast
Terminals zum Beispiel die Ostsee die
für die neuen Bundesländer und für den
kompletten Süden Baden-Württemberg und
Bayern ist das alles zu spät oder
halbherzig gemacht worden auch das Hin
und Her mit uniper schauen sie an uniper
erst ja wir unterstützen uniper dann
verstaatlichen übrigens mit der
spannenden Frage ich habe irgendwo
gelesen vielleicht stimmt es sogar dass
uniper ja im Ausland auch Anteile an
Kernkraftwerken hält werden die jetzt
eigentlich auch abgeschaltet oder wird
nur mit Kernkraft im Ausland gearbeitet
im eigenland nicht also das hätte in
jeder Beziehung die Union mit einem
klaren Kurs deutlich besser gemacht
haben sie in den vergangenen Tagen in
den vergangenen Wochen Unternehmer in
Bayern gehört aber auch Normalbürger die
sagen im Grunde will ich weg aus
Deutschland das ist meine Lösung
ja zunächst mal sind alle tief
verunsichert wie es weitergeht wir
müssen eine stille Insolvenzwelle
befürchten gerade der Mittelstand ist
tief verunsichert Bäcker Metzger ganze
Handwerk beispielsweise aber nicht nur
die deswegen war es auch letztendlich
auch auch gerade zu abstrus dass in
einem anderen Interview die grüne
Wirtschaftsministerin aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen zeitern sei nicht so
energieintensiv es scheint tatsächlich
das kleine Einmaleins der Ökonomie auch
nicht nur bei Habeck oder anderen
schwierig zu sein ich habe so das Gefühl
dass die Grünen in dieser Krise
schlichter überfordert sind sie sind
wahrscheinlich eine schönen wetterpartei
und mit diesen Situationen jetzt
überfordert leider hilft uns das nichts
jeder muss in die Gänge kommen auch der
Streit zwischen Linden und habe diese
eifersüchte leihen Schaden im Moment
natürlich es müsste jetzt so eine Art
whatever it takes kommen oder wie damals
Merkel und Steinbrück vor die Kameras
tragen sagen okay wir retten und retten
damals konnten sie erinnern sich in der
Finanzkrise so ein Signal bräuchtes
genaues bräuchte eine Garant und nur mit
einer Garantie dass man Gaspreise
Strompreise Spritpreise auch abfedert
kommt man durch den Winter was mich am
meisten allerdings wundert ist auch das
im unsere benachbarten Freunde in
europäischen Ländern bereits
gaspreisdeckel haben
tankrabatte verlängern nur Deutschland
macht es nicht ich verstehe diesen
Alleingang nicht und nur Deutschland
diskutiert heftig über Blackouts weil
man hier halt heftige Befürchtung haben
muss dass wir diese Blackouts erleben
haben sie diese Befürchtungen und wie
bereiten Sie sich vielleicht auch ganz
persönlich darauf vor
ich finde es übrigens dramatisch das
Teile der Bundesregierung der Parteien
ich habe heute gelesen in der
Bild-Zeitung das eben ich glaube
vergifer ich sag naja ein paar Stunden
kann man sich ja da drauf einstellen das
ist Teile der Bundesregierung verweigern
ja verweigern Strom für die Bevölkerung
die man die Kernkraft abschaltet also
verweigern blockierendes und machen dann
sich dann sozusagen Gedanken darüber was
man mit der Blackout macht das ist wie
diese ganze duschdebatte sorry jeder
soll Duschen wie er will es ist doch
keine Lösung für ein Land wie
Deutschland ein Industrie und
wohlstandsland dass wir kalt duschen
drei Stunden am Tag keinen Strom haben
Weihnachtsbeleuchtungen von vornherein
abschalten müssen das ist ja das für
eine
Zwangsidee und jeder geht schon hin und
sagt ah lasst ihr noch eure Beleuchtung
an man guckt schon mal in die Häuser
machen die abends dunkel sind die Zimmer
wirklich dunkel wie machen sie es mit
den Weihnachtsmärkten zum Beispiel ganz
konkret in Bayern werden die
abgeschaltet die Lichter
nein die vorläufig ja nicht wieso denn
auch sondern weil die Aufgabe ist doch
jetzt der Bundesregierung alles dafür zu
sorgen dass mehr Strom da ist
beispielsweise Verlängerung der
Kernenergie Anschluss der ganzen
Kohlekraftwerk da sind dann könnte
genügend Strom zur Verfügung stehen
Blackout kommt doch nur wenn man AKW
abschaltet Blackout kommt doch nur wenn
man auf der anderen Seite nicht genügend
Kohlekraftwerke anwirft und es bleibt
halt eine der ich befürchte eine
befürchte der
Lebenslügen der Grünen zu glauben man
kann alles gleichzeitig abschalten Kohle
kann Energie und wie wir gerade er
merken auch komplett Öl beispielsweise
denn viele Unternehmen stellen ja gerade
um also in Bayern wir haben das sehr
sehr stark unterstützt dass viele
Unternehmen weg vom Gas am mangels
Knappheit kommen können auch wieder zu
Öl bei aller Schwierigkeit die das ist
aber das wird noch funktionieren und man
sieht also leicht wird es nicht werden
es ist ja auch auffällig das Länder die
sehr bewusst auf erneuerbare Energien
setzen so wie Bayern übrigens auch das
aber alle noch auch ein Mindestmaß an
Gas oder auch beispielsweise Öl brauchen
ein Ergebnis sei dessen sind die montags
Proteste die immer mehr Zulauf erleben
jetzt auch eben gestern wieder und ein
Ergebnis ist dass die AFD mittlerweile
im Osten laut Insa stärkste Kraft ist
und auch in westdeutschen Bundesländern
wieder deutlich gewinnt warum eigentlich
warum landen die Stimmen nicht bei Ihnen
ja zunächst mal ist es so dass glaube
ich insgesamt dann die AFD versucht
daraus Honig zu sagen indem sie der
Politik
ein Versagen vorwirft und deswegen ist
es jetzt auch die entscheidende Frage zu
handeln morgen ist Ministerpräsident
Konferenz es ist die letzte Ausfahrt
wenn man das so sagen darf für Habeck
und Co auch für den Bundeskanzler dem
ich an der Stelle gute Besserung wünsche
wegen Corona er wird wohl süß der
derzeitige Stand zugeschaltet per Video
was wichtig ist wir müssten jetzt auch
Tacheles reden und wir müssen jetzt
Ergebnisse haben die endlose Verschieben
der Probleme löst es nicht sondern macht
es nur noch schlimmer man muss den Stier
sozusagen bei den Hörnern packen und
sagen was haben wir jetzt nötig was muss
getan werden allein des hin und
hergeschiebe mit Schattenhaushalten
Diskussionen um Sondervermögen wo man in
Berlin kaschieren will dass im Grunde
genommen seit langer Zeit die
Schuldenbremse ausgesetzt ist und man
dann sozusagen in Bürgern einzelne
kleine Rechnungen präsentieren will ist
alles wird nicht reichen meine
Empfehlung mein Rat ja mein Appell und
Förderung ist jetzt richtig zu agieren
um eine drohende Gefahr für unser Land
und für die Menschen abzuwenden apropos
Tacheles Friedrich Merz hat im Interview
hier bei Bild das Wort sozialtourismus
benutzt und hat diesen Bezug auf
ukrainische Flüchtlinge gesagt was haben
Sie bei diesem Wort bei diesem Satz von
Friedrich Merz empfunden
ich habe nur gelesen dass er sich
entschuldigt hat dafür deswegen war
meine Empfindung in dem Moment tot dass
ich das damit aus meiner Sicht erledigt
hat ich glaube an der Solidarität mit
der Ukraine und den ukrainischen
Menschen und Schutzsuchenden gibt es
keinen Zweifel der Freistaat Bayern hat
mit die meisten Menschen den meisten
Menschen aufgenommen Schutz gegeben und
jetzt auch viele viele Tausende von
Kindern gut in den Schulalltag gebracht
und eingeschult ja Friedrich Merz hat
sich entschuldigt und hat gleichzeitig
ein Phänomen aber angesprochen dass es
aus seiner Sicht zumindest in
Einzelfällen wir dann heute früh noch
mal schreibt gibt nämlich das
ukrainische Flüchtlinge pendeln hin und
her pendeln und eben Leistungen hier in
Deutschland in Anspruch nehmen dass
empfindet er als ungerecht kennen Sie
dieses Phänomen stimmt das
also ein eine Herausforderung haben wir
die hat nichts mit der Ukraine in dem
Sinn zu tun sondern generell die Zahl
der Flüchtlinge steigt sehr stark und
was das eigene Problem ist deswegen wird
das morgen auch besprochen werden bei
der ministerpräsenkonferenz der Bund
jedenfalls drückt sich um die Kosten es
gab klare zusagen und man darf wirklich
sagen bei steigenden Zahlen die ja vor
allem die Kommunen Landkreise Städte
belasten im Sinne von
unterbringungsverpflichtung die ja gut
sein soll
die führt jetzt dazu dass die Kosten
enorm steigen und der Bund lässt da
Städte und Landkreise allein zu sagen
werden nicht eingehalten deswegen ist
auch eine der Forderungen der
Beteiligung der Länder genau dazu sehen
die Kosten zu ersetzen und stärker
einzusteigen es ist ohnehin so was uns
alle etwas bewegt und was einem auch SPD
Ministerpräsidenten und müsste
Ministerpräsident unter der Hand ja
zugestehen auch meinen hochgeschätzter
Kollege aus Baden-Württemberg noch nie
gab es wohl eine sehr unfreundliche und
so unkooperative und so zentralistische
Philosophie wie bei der neuen
Bundesregierung das geht jetzt nicht nur
um unseren Streit Bayern und und Ampel
und so das Verhältnis ist sagen wir mal
sowieso relativ geklärt aber unabhängig
davon fällt es schon wirklich sehr auf
dass selbst SPD-Kollegen keine Ahnung
haben was Berlin plant und und ich
glaube nicht dass sie so funktioniert
natürlich gab es während der corona-zeit
viele Fehler und ich glaube sehr hier
oft diskutiert worden aber am Ende war
es immer so dass es den
schulterschlussbund und Länder gab und
es war schon die wichtigste Basis denn
die Länder sind ja die
Hauptverantwortung der Exekutive
nicht ermöglicht da ist die Stimmung ja
gelegt für den Ministerpräsidenten sind
groß ja die Stimmung ist nicht gut nee
die Stimmung ist nicht gut und zwar das
Ganze gibt es ja zu rechts aus zwei
Komponenten das eine ist die ist die
Schwere der Entscheidungen
und das andere ist der Stil mit dem
nicht entschieden oder oder eben nicht
kooperativ gehandelt wird meine
dringende Empfehlung auch da
große großes großes Besteck aufzulegen
zu Hilfe nicht die kleine Pinzette nicht
die kleine Kuchengabel und umgekehrt
auch kooperativ mit den Ländern zu sein
wissen Sie wenn man wenn man schnell
gehen will dann geht man alleine aber
wenn man weit gehen will dann geht man
gemeinsam die jetzige Bundesregierung
geht schnell und stolpert die ganze Zeit
weit kommt sie damit nicht noch mal zu
dem großen Besteck Friedrich Merz hat
auch in dem bildinterview gesagt die
Union sei jederzeit bereit wenn es auf
sie zukommt Regierungsverantwortung zu
übernehmen hat er recht und wenn ja auch
mit dem Kanzler März
zunächst mal ich glaube nicht übrigens
dass die Ampel aufgibt der dann eine
Ampel die aufgibt die gibt es dann nicht
mehr und da gibt es auch keinen der
beteiligten Parteien dann mehr dass die
Macht schweißt ja zusammen das ist ja
die seit Jahrzehnten kann man das ja
beobachten egal zu welchem Zustand sich
Regierungen befunden haben nur in mit
den aller aller seltensten Fällen hat so
eine Aufgabe gegeben und eine Ampel die
nach einem Jahr aufgibt nun ja äh dann
würde sich ja zeigen dass insbesondere
zwei Partner in keinster Weise
regierungsfähig sind ich will mich auch
nicht an sowas beteiligen ich glaube
dass die Union jederzeit regierungsfähig
ist wir haben auch genügend
Persönlichkeiten in der
Bundestagsfraktion in den Ländern die
miteinander die Verantwortung schultern
könnten aber es kommt jetzt nicht um Maß
kommt nicht auf macht an im März
vorneweg zum Beispiel ja aber es kommt
nicht auf macht dann ja Friedrich Merz
ist jetzt klar der Oppositionsführer und
damit die Nummer Eins in Berlin aber für
uns ist klar dass es jetzt eher darum
geht für die Menschen was zu erreichen
und weniger für uns
wir reden in diesem Gespräch Herr Söder
über ein Land in dem wir uns Gedanken
machen müssen ob es Blackouts gibt im
Winter wir reden über Turnhallen die
sich darauf vorbereiten Menschen mit
Decken zu versorgen weil so viele zu
Hause Ihre Heizung nicht mehr bezahlen
müssen und schlicht können und schlicht
frieren wir reden über ein Land in dem
im Grunde kein Vertrauen in diese
Regierung vorhanden ist und jetzt gucken
wir Fußball und sehen eine deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft die ja also
irgendwie auch nicht richtig auf dem
Platz bringt gibt es einen Zusammenhang
na ja die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft spielt da fast
besser als die Bundesregierung auf jeden
Fall und da habe ich auch noch mehr
Hoffnung drin denn es gab bei dem
gestrigen Spiel ja auch Hoffnung
zumindest gingen wir mal 2:0 in Führung
und was ich das eigentlich beachtliche
fand nachdem es dann zum Ausgleich kam
dann doch noch mal Tick nachzulegen und
eben nachdem man Rückstand kam eben
nicht sich aufzugeben also ich glaube
bei der Fußball-WM bin ich noch Optimist
deutlich optimistisch heißt bei der
Ampel was heißt das Finale Halbfinale
Viertelfinale jetzt können Sie festlegen
naja die Ampel übrigens im Unterschied
zu einer Fußballmannschaft spielt ihr
zunächst mehr mit gegen sich selbst ja
in der eine den Ball hat will dem
anderen nicht geben also da ist ein
anderer teamspiriert im deutschen Team
und und ich würde auch einfach sein dass
da Hansi fliegt der bessere teamcoach
ist als andere
ich würde mal so sagen wenn man die
Vorrunde gut überstehen dann ist alles
möglich ich glaube das schon dran ich
glaube übrigens auch fest daran dass bis
dahin aus der bayern-krise noch mal in
Bayern Turbo wird ja denn ohne Bayern
das sieht man übrigens dann geht ja auch
nichts ja also bei aller Bedeutung
anderer gibt es seit Wochen immer
Diskussionen und so weiter ohne Bayern
geht es nicht voran ein starkes Bayern
führt zu einem starken Deutschland und
ich hoffe dass da noch mal ein richtiger
Schuh kommt der beste ist muss Jala und
der kommt woher aus Bayern
na dann Markus Söder im Bild Interview
die richtigen Fragen an Bayerns
Ministerpräsidenten danke Ihnen für das
Gespräch
sehr gerne
[Musik]